we have been here for nine years
people come in here
and just want to tell me what's going on
in their life
so i had a woman that had come two or
three times
and she had this look on her face and i
said are you okay
and she looked at me and she said
no actually i'm not
and she said i didn't have anywhere to
go
i said what do you mean you didn't have
anywhere to go i said are you safe she
said no michelle i've just been told
that i have to have both of my breasts
removed and i have a 17 chance of
surviving it and i just realized i
didn't have anybody to tell
and of course my heart broke for her we
both sat there and cried
i didn't realize the impact that we had
in the community
when this virtual stranger came up to me
and decided to tell me
her death sentence basically
the community needs us as much as we
need them
and i know people are thinking well then
just quit just give up the business
at this point we've invested so much of
ourselves to just give it up
i'm not going to go down without a fight
i'll go down on my terms
with my fight
next time you go to your favorite
restaurant you may notice higher prices
beef rose nearly 57 percent in price
used to buy bacon for 240 a pound it
spiked up to six dollars in august 2021
almost 4.3 million americans quit their
jobs far too many restaurants have
indicated that they do not see a return
to anything approaching normal business
conditions this year amazon walmart the
big guys will find a way to get it done
but i think where the stress will be in
the system is in some of the littler
folks who who don't have the resources
the port of los angeles will open over
60 extra hours a week we have always
been open 24 hours a day so
it's not something new the only way to
resolve a pandemic driven supply
shortage is to end the pandemic why
aren't people coming back to work one of
them is child care of course which is
why the president's build back better
vision is going to be good for the labor
market before kovid before biden there
was a problem with child care and people
still went to work some folks have
raised worries that this could be a sign
of persistent inflation
but that's not our view it's going to go
down in history as one of the worst
inflation calls
by the federal reserve the policy makers
in washington
unfortunately
have
almost every month
been behind the curve what is the grand
home plan to increase oil production in
america
is hilarious
we did not qualify for ppp i had
incorporated two years ago so i was
self-employed
i was using students from the community
college there's a culinary program
so we didn't have anybody on payroll
we
incorporated we have people on payroll
now
but they wanted a longer time in
business
and we couldn't show that
i had a little girl who worked here for
me and quit
she quit because she got her stimulus
checked she had enough money to live on
for
i think she said 60 days
without having to depend on anybody
i said you're depending on that paycheck
i said you walk out that door
the door doesn't swing both ways
small restaurants like brood downtown
are having trouble with supply chains
having trouble with cost of services
in the old days we had small businesses
and towns those businesses would supply
the funding for things like fire
departments community activities youth
activities this little restaurant for
instance sponsoring even something as
simple as a little league team is now a
challenge because every dollar they make
has to go into just keeping the doors
open
it started to become harder to order
what we needed to order from our food
purveyors
it was you know this was out of stock
that was out of stock
the prices started to rise on everything
my cups were 500 cups in a case was
about 50
with the delivery and everything else
about 50
the last time i just ordered which was a
couple of weeks ago was 148
straws i had waited 16 weeks to get
straws all of those little things
started this this big snowball chain
of
how are we going to recover from this
85 of my customers are military
the median age of the military here in
jacksonville north carolina they're the
age of about 23 years old they're of a
low rank they make next to nothing so
i'm going to price my stuff
outside of the box from what they could
afford which i didn't want to have to do
that
then
everything went dead
i got a phone call from my rep saying
we're sorry us foods can no longer take
you as a customer
and i said you know i thought it was a
joke i have a good relationship with my
salesman and he was like no shell it
says it's making me sick he said this is
my commission this is my livelihood and
i'm telling you i can't service you it's
come down from above
that
we can't
and he was crying
we can't take you as a customer we can't
do it anymore so i'm pulling it off
and i said you know for what he said
well we're told
that they're only going to service the
larger accounts
and i said what does that mean a larger
account
and i hung up the phone and i blinked a
couple of times and i told my husband
and he's like what are we going to do
we were going out and buying a hundred
dollars worth of ham a hundred dollars
worth of turkey at the grocery store and
i kept seeing our bottom line
where we were
operating in the black we were starting
to dip into my red
and i finally got fed up i wrote to us
foods
i wanted somebody to hear me not just my
food rep
and i wrote to them and i heard nothing
i wrote to them again
and i heard nothing
the
the thing that crushed me
was that
why do we keep making the bigger
companies bigger
and allowing the smaller companies
to just go by the wayside
you know
when i was a kid
i was told the story of the ant and the
grasshopper
the grasshopper fed off of the ants who
did all the work and it wanted to be
entitled to the food and the harvest of
the ants but when winter came the ants
decided to take care of their own and so
they took the food down into their
shelter underground but the grasshopper
was too big to get into the ground and
he stood at the door and he said feed me
or i will starve
and beyonce looked at him and said
you go ahead and starve we will take
care of our own
this is what we are in danger of in this
country
i know that it's hard to change from
having an easy road
if you want to call it that i actually
think it's harder to receive than it is
to earn because you have to give up your
personal integrity and pride
i know that the american people can do
it we can invest in our community again
by investing our time our labor and our
resources to building an america
much more like what we grew up with
where the individual mattered the
individual counted and the small
business led the way to a strong
community
i think entrepreneurship is a grand idea
i think everybody from the span of time
where there was a job created
it was always
i could probably do that better or i
would do this differently and i think
entrepreneurship from its inception
kind of helped create every city in the
world
somebody had to start somewhere
the small business backbone across
america is is huge
but we tend to go with what we know we
know mcdonald's we know wendy's we know
taco bell and the brand recognition is
what they have to their advantage
what we have to our advantage is we put
our heart and soul into this
we put every
ounce of love into everything that we
make everything that we do and to our
customers and we like to feel that that
love and support is there for us as well
i think we just get overlooked
i will give my last penny if i have to
donate blood to keep the door open i
will because it's become as much a part
of us
as we are of it
you